[Music]
in conspiracy theory news more than
aliens ghosts I love conspiracy I
believe above aliens and posts oh I
think gooks as I believe in those too
yep
that's a new t-shirt brand right there
oh well usually referring to Latinos
oh no I assure you Latinos are real I've
heard submitted by Yee and that's with
threes at the end Oh a tech writer
suggests the popular 10 year challenge
may be collecting data for a facial
recognition algorithm I've heard of this
Shh tricked me [ __ ]
I was so confused about the 10 year
challenge what was the challenge behind
it showing off your cool photos was the
child on other challenges but these
necklace at throwback Thursday flashback
Friday yes more specific because it's a
10-year vain I want to see someone that
got worse yeah that's why I did the
opposite so my tenure was kind of cool
it was like a military photo and then
you know who did one that was really
good our friend Shannon she looked
busted and she was just talking about
how like she got more gray hair she's
like no one's being real on here she
wasn't wearing any makeup
shamone go glasses she was like
everything's [ __ ] up but she was in a
happier place mentally it's gotta said
you guys a pic of a ball sack and then
find then Tiger dangling
doing that as a joke I started laughing
to myself that I forgot to send it back
and then it was time to smile like this
send it to me don't be the next
throwback Thursday anyway so this
fortune 500 advisor named Kate O'Neill
and she's also a tech writer she said
this quote meaning ten years ago
probably would have played along with
the profile picture aging meme going
around on Facebook and Instagram me now
Ponder's how all this data could be
mined to train facial recognition
algorithms on age progression and age
recognition that's good we want them to
catch criminals no sure or missing
people yeah so they are saying like
those could be the good things about it
but then the other like dark side of the
song like it's like what's what is the
end goal here like why are they
collecting so much data I'm like how
where if this is true on how we're aging
and like what's the evil thing behind it
well wait they've been doing that if you
really think about it because in
California need a driver's license and
you need to renew it every few years so
why are people going oh I'm not gonna do
this it's like while they do it on your
passport they do it on your driver's
license like if you use Instagram or
snapchat with all those like facial
filter things how do you think that
works they did they map out your face to
show you mapping out your face and that
was something I believe a little bit
more but to go back and spit like the
only reason that that would be a thing
is that they specifically wanted a
ten-year gap which people don't even
adhere to I was like this is like eight
and a half for me haha do you do it to
the T though are your driver's license
is the passport so you should be more
scared about that it's not gonna work on
the [ __ ] Asian [ __ ] that face to
in their face you know I thought so many
ten years challenges where they're like
I look the same you use face tune [ __ ]
of course you look the same you hope
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
but you can't just modify your face and
say you kept your age like you look like
[ __ ] now I know I see you person if
there if this was a conspiracy like what
did they think NSA just like they were
in the marketing room like we need to
think of a challenge like we need to do
something that's what it is governments
close down they can't do that so it's on
their free time yeah
your challenge and I like everybody
things are so [ __ ] important like
you're not that important nobody gives a
[ __ ] about you just like that dude at my
parents store that would hide his
[ __ ] ATM number as I bring you got 12
dolls in there nobody wants to steal
that [ __ ] I don't give my information
out I don't want you steal my [ __ ]
color I do not kill myself dude how
about that dude you [ __ ] weirdo you
know I think does probably take your
stuff is like when people are doing
those celebrity look-alike challenges
and sharing that because either they
look kind of like the celebrity that it
spits back out at them or they look
nothing like it but either way you're
sharing it you're like I don't look like
flippin Bon Jovi and then they share it
and then other people do it and it
doesn't like they're winning either way
so I'm like what do those people get out
of it as opposed to my crew because this
doesn't use a specific app you're just
posting and then people could already
get your photo like you brought up a
throwback Thursday it's the same thing
yeah so but I do think people are
probably doing started this 10-year
challenge the government knows yeah it's
NSA's marketing department oh maybe
that's what makes it really suspicious
you can't take it to a specific source
someone was blaming Facebook for
starting it and then Facebook tweeted
back to that person saying the 10 year
challenge is a user-generated meme that
started on its own it's evidence of the
fun people have on Facebook and that's
it that was a response for that they
were like we didn't do it because you
know how Facebook isn't so much I caught
water right now video just like sell
everyone's data no we're in Western
civilization
you know that there's yeah there's more
to it than that
I think frontline did a crazy
documentary on them it's a two-hour
special that everyone should watch
because it's pretty insane how Russia
had these troll farms and they
infiltrated our Facebook and in a lot of
the protests that we had they actually
created that yeah like they've already
like proven and traced it back to their
tro farms and a example is there's this
mosque in dallas i think it was a dallas
and last yeah but they created a alright
group a facebook page or like a group
right and started inviting people and
then they had like several fake accounts
so it'd be like John from Houston or
whatever right and then they would get
these people route
and they would try to like market fake
news like editorials and they would go
in there and they would get them all
fired up and they're like all right
we're gonna on this day we're gonna go
protest these like Islamic extremists or
whatever at this mosque and then they
created like a like a very liberal LGBT
group and until like we got to go there
and protect them and so they round up
these two groups and on that day like
thankfully no violence erupted but they
got the two groups there together to
fight yeah that's crazy you know how
like I'm super into like military like
special ops like knowledge stuff yeah so
I was just like googling all like the
different branches there are so now
under like the Special Forces for all
the army one of the divisions is like
the human psychology and Civil Affairs
one and their job is to make social
media accounts and to Hue and to
influence people's psychology and other
nations so they can have nations crumble
from within it's so much more effective
than sending like a highly trained
soldier and going there like being like
ninjas and stuff so now they can do
things in a way where they just cause
complete distrust they implode yeah when
they pretty much implode and it's so
it's like what you're reading on social
media you don't really know what the
source or what the intention is at the
moment like our ants joined Facebook is
like when it was all downhill because
it's like that generation doesn't know
that's exactly right and they don't know
how to like pick out the information be
like you know if they're reading a book
they'd be like what's the source but on
the internet they're just like that's a
fact
yeah and like the second you like
something on Facebook the algorithm is
gonna show you more of that stuff so
you're already so easily targeted that's
why it's like red feed vs. blue feed
thing if you've ever seen that it's
you're just showing what you already but
yeah I felt uses these guys thinking
about how to piss these nations off it's
just one person typing you look fat in
that t-shirt yeah what the [ __ ] and they
get super [ __ ] mad it's like it's not
even that hard to like piss off an adult
- I know and adults always think that
they're above like the children they're
like oh yeah kids they're so dumb look
at this it's like have you seen your
[ __ ] Facebook you
you're worse than these kids dude either
bicker about the dumbest things and
every single thought that an old person
had they have to write it on Facebook
yes yeah I don't [ __ ] know like they
have to be sitting there they go you
know what I don't like this [ __ ] about
our government and it's like all my
older relatives are doing it yeah it's
like what the [ __ ] are they doing senior
wars sometimes I have to ask him it's
like do you work anymore are you how are
you doing this like it's a lot of energy
and they go back and forth constantly
it's unreal
my dad's in his facebook like that but
his favorite TV show to watch is this
like political debate thing in China
Oh see they debate politically in China
it's a one-party system the baby
it's like spits they're actually not
they're not there like analysts are the
government so there's like two or three
or four sides and they're just
constantly roasting going in on each
other like my dad for that I love that
see even in that [ __ ] crazy world of
guys yeah looks like a team sport now
right like it's like you're talking
about football teams now it's like you
know you're not putting faces to the
names you're just like those liberals
are those conservatives then it becomes
like in a Facebook argument like well
how about it'll be like a totally
different topic and I'll be like well
how about you leave tards talking about
this thing and you're like all right
well no one was talking about that but
sure let's talk about it and they have
[ __ ] it I mean at the end of the day
what people have to remember though is
you know if you're of if you're from
America where we are American that you
know and there are other outside forces
that are trying to use our democracy
against us and [ __ ] with us and it's
really becoming a polarizing nation
because there's a lot of idiots with too
much information
[Music]
[Music]